l'ennemi nous a attaqués par surprise
jamais cette lettre vous parvient il y
apporte à craindre je ne serai plus de
ce monde à dieu
ce qui vous est arrivé vous avez détesté
je me suis très mal conduit avec pauline
pauline on n'est même pas pris le temps
lui écrire alors je me suis fait passer
pour vous mais cris quelques lettres
mais dans la dernière je vous ai faite
foot et les revenus
voici passe admin anglais qui chargent
dans ma direction et je coupe être
imposture ne tiendra pas toujours
capitaine comment vous en êtes vous
sorti
malheureusement que j'ai perdu une
partie de la mémoire suite à une version
à la tête ou sa salle à tête où ça à la
tête
eh bien voyez justement même ça je m'en
souviens plus
[Musique]
j'ai cru alors madère d'erreur arriver
mais j'habitais un mur et vers lequel je
courus pour d'un bon sommeil sur deux
les promontoires dominé l'ennemi et le
forcer à s'exposer pour m'attendre je
coupe un doigt des mois les bras dessous
nous vous ne m'aurez pas à l'ancien
l'anglais vous n'aurez pas car c'est
notre combat dès l'empiré tlm la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est bien mais comment avez-vous survécu
votre dernière lettre faisait tout de
même état d'une situation désespérée
oh oui racontez nous racontez-nous
comment vous vous êtes sorti c'est un
passe temps dans ce fortin avec cette
poignée d'hommes et ses 2000 anglais qui
vous encercler brûlante envie d'en
entendre les moindres détails
malheureusement les détails se sont un
peu effacé g j'ai perdu une partie de la
mémoire certaines nations à la tête ou
sa tête où ça à la tête
eh bien voyez justement même ça je m'en
souviens plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je fais voler pauline l'empereur écraser
ses autriche
ils seront tous les jours je vous le
promets
des cris ou pas c'est un séducteur voilà
la vérité un séducteur
[Musique]
il ya trois ans vous êtes parti pour le
tri
pauline est mariée et mère de deux
enfants il pourrait elle vous est mort
et enterré sur sa gauche n'ont même pas
pris le temps de m'écrire
alors je les fais moi voilà je me suis
fait passer pour vous et je l'écris
quelques lettres devant la dernière je
vous ai fait toute l'attention des
villes vous êtes parent héros ce serait
dommage de tout l'est chez nous à huy le
vix les revenus
tout ça pour un acteur c'est étiez parti
c'est tout c'est ça vous avez perdu la
raison
voici 2 face à 2000 anglais qui chargent
en ma direction ils ne sont plus qu'à
100 m on doit ce bourg sur la détente et
la cavalerie est arrivé c'est à la chute
c'est nul je vous la corde mais c'est ma
vie et on la choisit pas il va être un
peu dur ne tiendra pas toujours si je
tombe vous tombez avec moi c'est un peu
fatigué j'allais me reposer dans une
chambre à l'étagé la dernière au bout du
couloir soir non pardon je tendais
quelqu'un d'autre une autre fois
peut-être ou non vous êtes en train de
dénaturer mon oeuvre
le capitaine que j'ai créé des files est
subtile ailleurs je ne suis rien ici je
suis le capitaine de ville
vous avez fait vous du spa j'avais
compté 11
[Musique]